while every dogs nose is pretty  sensational so for instance a tracking  dog who's following a person who has  gone missing and finds footsteps but  doesn't know which direction they're  going can tell which direction by the  difference in odor concentration of the  first and the fifth footstep so in other  words the first footstep will have  slightly less odor than the one they  took two seconds later the fifth  footstep and that's how they tell which  direction the person is gone so in that  way I think odor is actually telling  time for dogs it's telling them what was  here more recently or what's about to  arrive I can smell something on the wind  and what was here a long time ago a  smell that's lost concentration and is  diminishing on the ground so I think  that acuity and that ability to kind of  tell time with smell is pretty  astounding  [Music]